Jeffrey Epstein is expected to appear in
federal court in New York today the
disgraced financier is in jail awaiting
trial he is accused of sexually abusing
dozens of underage girls some as young
as 14 years old mola leggy as at the
Metropolitan Correctional Center in New
York City where Epstein is being held
molo what do we expect today
well good morning today prosecutors and
defense attorneys are expected to
discuss a possible trial date for
Jeffrey Epstein
the 66 year old registered pedophile is
on around-the-clock 24-hour suicide
watch here at the Correctional Facility
after just last week he was found
injured disoriented and crying on the
floor of his jail cell that incident
remains under investigation the US
Attorney's Office tells me that that
apparent suicide attempt could be
brought up later in court today earlier
this month
Epstein was charged with sex trafficking
and conspiracy charges for the alleged
sex abuse of underage girls in the early
to mid-2000s charges that Epstein
pleaded not guilty to federal judge
Richard Berman later denied Epstein's
multi-million dollar bail proposal so
Epstein is expected to remain in custody
here at the Correctional Facility
through his trial
today's hearing comes as we await the
release of nearly two thousand pages of
sealed documents from a civil case that
could greatly expand the scope of this
investigation
well we've been waiting the release of
those documents for a while now what
exactly do we think is in them that's
something a lot of people are wondering
many questions about what is in those
documents names specifically is what
we're expecting to learn and how those
names are linked allegedly linked to
Jeffrey Epstein but the nature of those
relationships Anthony that is what
remains unclear alright molla thank you